generally it has been said that
tricks and traps doesn't work against
title player
but now imagine a line where more than
15 GMS
and 30 plus other title players has
fallen for the Trap
isn't that something special
well that's the topic of today as we are
going to witness one of the most high
profile GM level trap in the Carlson's
Queens can be declined from the white
perspective
[Music]
after D4
black and choose either of the mortar
I am going to show you the proper
Queen's Gambit decline more order
D5
C4
E6
and after Knight to C3
rather than playing Knight to F6 black
plays
this Carlson's modern move A6
so idea is very simple if white is not
careful then black is looking to capture
on C4 and then quickly lash out with B5
which in some lines can hold on to this
extra Pawn
so of course white shouldn't allow this
and accordingly
one of the most popular choices C
captures D5 e captures D5 Knight to F3
Knight web six
and now Bishop to G5 pinning down that
Knight threatening Bishop captures F6
followed up with Knight captures D5
once again the old move in this position
is Bishop to E7
however that Bishop will remain passive
so that's why if you look at the
database here by far Bishop to E6 is the
modern reply where black is remain
flexible not only is defending the D5
Pawn but later on this dark Square
Bishop can come out on the active Square
namely D6
okay now we are dive into some forcing
line
Bishop takes F6 Queen takes up six
Queen to B3 attacking two sports
but black is not bother about D5 Pawn as
if white capture this with the Knight
then his Knight will remain pink
so accordingly by far
the most logical response is B5 and
after A4 renewing the threat of
capturing this Pawn black plays the move
B4
hitting the C3 mount
well we have reached to the most
important Junction of the strap
and you might think that Knight captures
D5 is completely not possible due to the
simple move Queen to d8 and that Knight
is a complete corner right
and yes indeed it's true except guess
what
he's playing this wonderful move
so isn't that look crazy because after
Queen to d8
black will be delighted as this Knight
is simply a gunner
because after E4 and C6
that night indeed disappeared from the
bow
but the most amazing part is this is
exactly what is aiming for
there is a killer move here
and if you want you can stop the video
and find it by yourself I'm showing you
right now
Queen to E3 look at this
so beautiful
and still I am sure just like me if you
see this position first time you are
scratching your head what exactly going
on as after Pawn takes D5 e takes D5 and
queen captures D5 isn't black a whole
piece up
and where is the compensation there is
absolutely no attack can see from this
position
well that's the beauty about this trap
as following two moves by the Y in fact
kill the plaque in the opening stage
look at this first move
Rook to C1
so now we have a simple thread
Bishop to C4 and then push on with D5
whereupon white regained the peace with
the interest and don't forget in some
lines we can also throw this Rook to see
you check
so if black doesn't identify these
threads correctly then the game might
finish very quickly
for example
there is a game in the database where a
strong black player has been crossed
elegantly after he played this
disastrous move Knight to C6
okay no price for guessing what's next
reply Bishop to C4
Queen to E5 so black is indeed looking
for the Discover check
but the big time problem is after Bishop
takes E6 Pawn takes E6 and Rook Tech C6
not only white has regained his peace
back but there is a indeed threat of
capturing on E6
which even after the move B3
and King to E2
black cannot stop it and see yourself
after all this how quickly game has been
finished
as Queen to D5 has been played white
give this check
King to F7 and now the last piece
joining into the party with Rook to
Sivan
well black thought that is still in the
game with Bishop to D6 stopping Rook to
C7 and connecting The Rook
but after Knight to G5 I think game is
already a gunner
he played King to fade
only to get the root shock
well if your opponent King is dancing in
the center then the sacrifices are bound
to be happened
let's see the beautiful sequence Queen
captures D6
Queen to F3 check
King to E7
now comes another dazzling Moon Rook to
C7 check
black is forced to capture it but after
Queen check
Knight to E6 came to C8 and queen
capture C7 we have a picturesque
Checkmate on the table
where throughout the game black has not
given a single chance to show up his
talent
okay so by far the most accurate
response here is Bishop to E7
unpinning the E6 Bishop so now there is
no threat of Rook to C8 as well as
Bishop to C4
but now amazingly enough why come up
with the second big resource namely
Bishop to D3
and this time around the different
thread that is Bishop to E4 and nabbing
the exchange
so accordingly once again if you look at
the database
white has tried two major choices number
one
taking out that room or playing either
Queen to D7 or queen to B7
so let's see each by Tone and find out
what white has up in a Slave
number one Rook to A7
highestly played move but I'm afraid
this is a big time mistake as after
Bishop to E4
we are indeed threatening the move D5
something which is very difficult to
stop
a very modal example for this liner is a
strong International master
here continue with Queen to B3 so his
idea is to exchange the queen but this
quickly backfired with the following
night sequence by white Rook to see a
check
you cannot take with the bishop as your
queen is hanging
and if you move the king then The Rook
drops so in the game by force black has
to play Bishop to d8
but after that white simply gobble up
the piece with Rook captures be it
and now funny enough white is more than
happy if black exchanged the queen as
the resulting position favors the white
with a clear Pawn advantage so in the
game black chose the move Rook to E7
trying to exploit a white king and queen
position
but white has calculated
far more better than black
first he give this check
whereupon black just delighted by
playing Bishop to D7
executing what he wants to do but
exactly here White shows the power of
His calculation
starting with Bishop captures D7
King takes D7
Rook to B7 check
and finally after King to see it and
Rook captures E7
black to his horror find out that he
can't even touch this Rook as his Queen
is hanging and if black take this queen
then white will obviously recapture with
the rook and in all of these lines it is
white who has emerged with the whole
Rook up
foreign
probably the most accurate response here
is
moving the queen either through D7 or B7
let's say D7 in this game
and after Bishop to E4 black should play
Queen to A7
giving up the Rook grabbing the two PS
and holding on to the scale
kindly note that Queen 2 A7 also
stopping the move D5 as black can simply
swap up the queen and getting the peace
advantage
so the big question arise now what to do
whether white is going to capture the
rook in the corner and satisfy with his
position
well of course not
as this is what I like about this trap
is
look at White's next move
Queen to F4
unbelievable stuff
you are pieced down and you're playing
such moves
really this is a crafty design trap
well now White's idea is very nasty he
has stopped the exchange of the queen so
he's threatening two things
number one be far and the second one
most important Rook to see Circle
and believe it or not even though black
is a piece of engine suggests that
what is literally dominating this
position
well the most accurate response here is
Knight to D7
but after D5 white indeed grabbed the
piece back
with a completely Superior position
and I just like to highlight how
problematic this position is
s if you play a normal move such as
Castle in this position then after Pawn
takes E6 and F takes E6 what can play
the move Queen to G4
whereupon in the most of this line is
likely to gobble up this weak E6 Pawn
with a clear Pawn advantage
so that's not a good choice for the
black
and as per the database
let me show you a Allied game
where a 2600 plus GM continue here with
G5
trying to complicate the game but still
it doesn't work out as after the
following sequence Knight captures G5
Bishop captures G5
Queen captures G5
black played the move Queen to D4
so that if you now take on E6 then Queen
captures E4 comes with a check
but now White shows the power of his
position by simply
gasoline on the king side
saying that yup you can have another
piece
but the end result is Pawn takes E6
F takes E6 black king has been caught in
the center
and it is just a matter of time where
white Rook Unleashed and Checkmate the
black king
look how quickly white won the game
Rook to even happen
Queen to G6
Queen to D5 so double attack looking at
Pawn as well as on The Rook so by force
black has to play King to E7
but after Rook to C6
sadly enough the E6 Pawn is going down
with a check
and moves like Knight to f8 doesn't work
here because of Rook to C7
in the game black goes for this tactical
sequence Rook as to EA and his idea is
that after Rook captures E6 he wants to
play King to f8 so that white now cannot
take this queen as black is simply
threatening a checkmate
but now White shows how pathetic black
position is by executing the following
sequence
Queen to D6 Jack
King 127
Queen captures D7 Jack
King to f8
once again we have this queen check and
finally after King 127
white deliver this queen to F4 check
which by force wins the game as now
black king has to go to the G file
whereupon we can simply NAB the queen
with the check
and forcing black to resign the key
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile trap
in the Carlson's qgd
remember at this Junction
play this nasty night sacrifice with
Knight captures D5
and even after black winning the piece
with the following sequence white has a
very nice move in this position namely
Queen to E3
whereupon even though black get the
peace after Rook to C1
no matter however black wriggles
in most of the lines
white regained the peace back with the
interest
and the added bonus is black king remain
in the center
where white and joy all sorts of attack
as many strong GMS and title players has
fallen for this trap you can use this
line as a complete surprise weapon in
the tournament practice
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon
bye and take care